enfin nous voici à brest avec toute
notre équipe de flâneurs jeudi enfin car
cette ville nous attirer pour des
raisons contradictoires comme une ville
qui nous attire et que l'on repousse en
même temps trop aimé trop mal aimé brest
et ses romantisme ses nostalgies à tous
les étages malgré une architecture
urbaine qui celle de l'après guerre
l'architecturé urbaine qui tue le rêve
dans l'oeuf alors brest et sa rade la
plus belle du monde sa honte c'est brest
c'est l'arsenal
c'est la rue de siam c'est la
recouvrance c'est cayenne épicé
aujourd'hui océanopolis
le brest auquel richelieu donna aussi
son destin de port militaire
et ça continue bon on verra dans quelle
condition le brest de mac orlan qui dans
les années 20 voyait dans cette ville
l'une des plus curieuses du monde
s'insinuant perfidement dans
l'imagination des hommes par son
admirable mélange de vie et de mort
le brest de jacques prévert au barbara
quelle connerie la guerre
le brest dans hick et feleke dont la
plume s'arrête a définitivement le 13
janvier 1992 sur ces mots le brest
énergiquement actuelle invite à
réfléchir de bonne foi aux nuits du
passé en sachant que nous n'aurons
jamais que des réponses obscures alors
nous allons tâcher d'éclairer quelques
lanternes sur brest et avec d'ailleurs
qu'est fennecs qui rappelle que les
trois premières lettres de brest cbr e
bretagne et que la fin du nom de brest
désigne l'est c'est à dire l'europe vers
laquelle elle est toujours tourné
[Musique]
comment
oui voici l'un des derniers nés des
monuments de brest voyez on peut en
forme de crabe avec les pattes des deux
côtés architecture novatrice et
unificatrice disent les brochures
touristiques
c'est aussi à nos polices alors ici se
tiennent des congrès ici on visite des
tas de choses très intéressantes sur la
mer comme disait mac orlan ici à brest
le grand jeu c'est la mer tout va à la
mer aux choses de la mer aux hommes de
la mer et océanopolis a voulu relever ce
défi très anciens on va voir son
directeur scientifique et culturel eric
hussenot
[Musique]
on
eric hussenot c'est un univers
passionnant votre océanopolis mais quel
objectif
est ce que est ce que ça poursuit le but
de l'opération c'est de montrer
plusieurs choses d'une part d'abord de
montrer l'ensemble des technologies ils
sont des activités des chercheurs en
bretagne qui est considéré qu'il avait
mal à faire avec le cnrs ifremer oui on
ira à nancy puis en bretagne qui sont
très très important montre un petit peu
au public et aux français qu'elle est qu
elle l ensemble de ses activités c'est
la première dès la première de nos de
nos objectifs
le deuxième c'est aussi de faire
découvrir l'ensemble des phénomènes qui
font vivre les océans pour fonctionner
les océans oui c'est tout con
scénographie en général ça oui comment
fonctionnent les marais en fonction des
marées le troisième objectif c'est aussi
de faire découvrir la vie dans les mers
en bretagne savez qui a une vie qui est
extrêmement riche
alors nous n'avons pas d'accord même
tropicaux des acomptes radicaux qui sont
très colorés mais nous avons cette
diversité de la faune et de la flore
bretonne cette abondance est fou de
cette flore et enfin le la le dernier de
nos de lot de l'autre formation apport
cet apport exactement faut rentrer dans
le port
et là ce que l'on veut faire découvrir
un petit peu c'est tous les problèmes de
la navigation la sécurité en mer je
savais qu'à la pointe de bretagne et un
trafic considérable qui passe tous les
jours est l'une de nos missions c'était
de parler un petit peu la navigation la
sécurité
m
on
[Musique]
non
résumant les choses vous n'êtes pas un
parc d'attractions on n'est pas parc
d'attractions on est un peu à part
quatre actions dans la mesure où il ya
énormément du site heures qui viennent
la police oui combien elle a ce quelque
chose autour de 1 million 300 mille
visiteurs depuis l'ouverture il ya deux
ans et demi maintenant c'est vraiment un
pour un équipement de provinces ciblées
c'est vraiment une très forte
fréquentation et puis le côté
scientifique et puis l aspect il ya tout
l'aspect scientifique donc là de montrer
un peu les les technologies les
technologies de la bretagne la richesse
de ces technologies ça travaille avec
ils feraient mieux reçus en étroite
collaboration avec l'ifremer mais vous
aussi avec l'université vous avez des
laboratoires du cnrs vous avez le
collège de france il ya un potentiel
savoir à la pointe de bretagne
vous avez le potentiel chercher un
scénographe le plus important d'europe
bonjour vincent rey l'eau le vent vous
êtes mal juin au directeur scientifique
ici et je ne m'attendais passe de
phoques
les visites sont interdites merci de
nous accueillir quand même pour les
besoins de la formation et du reportage
d'accord et pourquoi avez-vous des
fautes
qu'est-ce qu'il aurait il ya des des
petites populations de l'époque en
bretagne qui sont résidents qui habitent
ici s'y reproduisent et quelquefois dont
certains jeunes poissons perdu où je
dirais peut-être en difficulté sur le
bien se nourrissent pas bien ou bien
n'ont pas été suffisamment allaité
pendant le relais tout merci mènent de
leur vie après ils sont plus rapidement
en difficulté puis n'ont pas de réserves
de graisse et puis l'apprentissage ça
fait très doucement tandis que la chasse
maryse et puis je leur réserve et puis
on les trouve sur la côte et ils ont
froid inanimé wes animé inanimé oui
c'est fatigués on vous les amènera les
gens nous les amènent bon et alors vous
leur faites quoi alors bon souvent et
notamment à son très faible parce que
vous avez besoin réserves sur cet état
de faiblesse générale souvent ils ont
aussi en plus des plaies des maladies en
respirant des parasites des tas de
choses comme ça qui viennent un peu
compliqué l'histoire et après une fois
réglé c'est pour les motos logique
l'essentiel c'est de reconstituer leurs
réserves de graisse donc aliments venait
alimenter mais vraiment leur donner un
coup de pouce très significatif dans ce
domaine c'est à dire que ils arriveront
les gaver les gars quand il accepte
quand ils n'acceptent pas eux mêmes mais
en ce moment on préfère qu'il prenne
lui-même mais ça met un certain temps à
venir
au début généralement il faut dégager et
donc généralement ils arrivaient à 15 kg
c'est un petit peu le poids critique
c'est le poids qu'ils avaient
connaissance ça veut dire quand ils ont
quinze kilos ils ont tout perdu nos
réserves de graisse et après nous on va
les repousser jusqu'à vers 35 40 kg
avant de les relâcher
à
il ya des phoques en bretagne il ya des
fois pas mentalement il y a deux
colonies connues
et puis en plus de ces de glo ni il ya
certainement des populations plus
diffuse un peu partout les gens sur la
côte les connaissent il ya des tas de
noms d'ailleurs le nom de rochers qui
font référence aux phoques est bon ça
fait partie du patrimoine naturel de la
bretagne 2,8
il y aurait beaucoup plus sur les
grosses il ya des canadiens port nord
disons qu'on est ici la limite sud pour
une espèce de phoques gris et qui est
très très abondant dans les îles
britanniques
surtout en écosse merci vincent ridoux
océanopolis c'est en quelque sorte la
grande vitrine de toutes les recherches
qui sont faites sur la mer qui est
peut-être dans le futur notre mère
nourricière et participent à l'activité
de ceux de ce centre océanopolis ifremer
célèbre institut de recherche
on va voir ce qui se passe haifa mer
deux exemples de france 3 iroise
des générateurs de houle il en existe
déjà en france mais celui l'ifremer
brest et le premier en europe à être
installé sur un bassin très profond 20
mètres en l'occurrence ce qui devrait
permettre aux scientifiques brestois de
mener des études inédites votre énoncé
le profond c'est donc tout ce qui va
concerner l'exploitation des richesses
sociales profondes
quand on dit profond sept ans 3-0 et 600
mm de profondeur
c'est le credo des installations des
matériels flottant qui ne bouge pas
beaucoup par rapport au pont qui
supporte des tuyaux des risers et des
pailles paix les systèmes et qui
permettent de travailler depuis la
surface vers le pont ou qui sont
statiques par rapport au front sous
forme de plateformes de grâce à ce
générateur ifremer devrait pouvoir
étudier également l'action de la houle
sur les bateaux de pêche
vous prenez l'exemple d'un filet qui
fait quelques centaines de mètres de
long 1 chez lui qui fait quelques
centaines de mètres de long d'une
semaine at-on qui va faire 2000 qui à
2000 mètres de long la proportion entre
le bateau et ski très net une proportion
qui nécessite que l'on veut garde bien
le comportement du bateau avec ce bassin
on peut modéliser déchets raisonnable
tout ce qui est apparue de pêche et on
peut étudier le comportement de
l'ensemble dans la houle c'est-à-dire
approcher les conditions de sécurité du
travail à la mer et des conditions
également limite d'exploitation
l'étude de la houle devrait devenir une
des plus importantes activités l'ifremer
à brest dès que la période de mise au
point du générateur sera achevé d'ici
quelques mois comment seront les
premières expériences avec modèles
réduits
comment évaluer la montée du niveau des
océans l'aggravation de l'effet de serre
pour répondre rapidement à des questions
aussi cruciales
les scientifiques ont besoin d'outils
performants c'est pour eux qu'ils
feraient maire a mis au point deux
flotteurs marc bord dont les derniers
essais de résistance une forte pression
sous-marine ont lieu à brest une
centaine de flotteurs de ce type seront
bientôt immergée au large du brésil et
fourniront des informations précieuses
sur le déplacement des masses d'eau
antarctique et atlantique
le chanteur est un positionner donc
entre deux eaux suit le va suivre le
déplacement de la masse d'eau pendant la
durée de trois ans en même temps d'en
bas va faire une mesure de température
et de pression
une fois par jour la connaissance de ses
dossiers dépassement est important dans
la mesure où les messes d'autres en fait
en fait de la des quantités de chaleur
d'un point à un autre sur le globe
terrestre et ses transferts de chaleur
sont tout à fait important pour
connaître l'évolution du climat de la
terre
l'originalité du flotteur mme harbour
c'est que grâce à un système hydraulique
intégré il peut plonger et remonter
régulièrement à la surface pour
transmettre ces informations à 7 et les
argos
alors qu'avec les anciens flotteur les
scientifiques devaient attendre la fin
du programme de mesures pour commencer
leur travail d' analyse les responsables
brestois fiers de leurs vitrines sont
aussi de ce qui est à l'intérieur avec
tout ce qui est en chantier ici avec
tout ce qui existe aussi
ils sont vraiment résolument tourné vers
l'avenir et ils veulent se développer
sur trois axes l'océanographie
l'agroalimentaire et l'informatique
électronique
mais les brestois savent aussi qu'ils
reviennent de très loin
ils reviennent de pas mal de crise
économique ils reviennent de pas mal de
déchirements politiques et surtout il a
fallu se relever des ruines de
l'après-guerre et ça a été très long
[Musique]
enfin
chaque prêt vert rappelle toi barbara
il pleuvait sans cesse sur brest ce
jour-là au barbara il pleut sans cesse
sur brest mais ce n'est plus pareil
et tout est abîmée c'est une pluie de
deuil terrible et désolé ce n'est même
plus l'orage de fer d'acier de sens tout
simplement des nuages qui traîne comme
des chiens et vont courir au loin au
loin très loin de brest dont il ne reste
rien ou de 40 début des bombardements
anglais qui se multiplient en 41 53 puis
allemand stationnent dans le port des
bus 43 ans ferme les écoles les
populations commencent à évacuer et du
printemps 44 à 70 44 c'est le déluge de
feu de fer d'acier de sang sur les 1200
habitants qui était quand même rester à
brest 345 mourront dans l' incendie de
la bri sadi carnot brest dont il ne
restait rien repris l'appel et la pioche
et l'architecte urbaniste mathon conçu
bas une ville militaire il fallait faire
vite une ville au carré à l'américaine
alors évidemment on dira que c'est moche
c'est moche
que reste-t-il aujourd'hui de tout cela
eh bien c'est une ville qui a bougé
c'est une ville qui essaie de sortir de
sa monotonie avec plus ou moins de
bonheur et impression là dessus valérie
heures tél
reste la neuve une ville damier aux
couleurs du béton avec des rues trop
large ou le vent s'engouffre
roger goodell anciens brest vous savez
le bain je trouve un peu triste quand
même vite tombé malade à qui servent pas
ce franchement parler et bien je la
trouve triste parce que je l' ai connu
beaucoup plus gai que ça je suis
responsable et à la fois j'avoue qu'elle
ne bouge pas beaucoup
quarante années plus tard nostalgie
d'une vieille ville
pourtant depuis quelques années brest
l'a9 est en train de changer
rch âmes qui se sont bien aujourd'hui de
la rue thiam d'autrefois les bacs à
fleurs bleues ont cédé la place à des
fontaines des fontaines contesté qui
sont l'oeuvre de marta pan une artiste
roumaine
pourquoi ne vous faites pas content
parce que ça semble assez fier à des
pairs de cimetière c'est si triste et
gris c'est moi c'est déjà cabinet ac
grise comme ça j'aurais pu mettre des
arts quelque chose de plus gai triste la
ville de brest par dans tous les
quartiers
dans les ruelles de saint-martin que
l'on restaure d'année en année on est au
coeur du vieux brest et sur la jolie
place guérin joueurs de boules petit
bistrot et flâneurs rendre à la ville
une histoire et un petit air du cid
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et à la nuit tombante
quand d'autres villes s'endorment brest
rude et douce à la fois subtile et
discrète révélera ses charmes à ceux qui
avec allieront au goût tout au bout de
la nuit
[Musique]
oui
les musiciens et les chanteurs auteurs
compositeurs ont toujours aimé cette
ville brest qui le leur rend bien
d'ailleurs
et il ya 20 ans un étudiant en médecine
originaire de la lande de douarnenez
basse amy a épousé plutôt la poésie et
la musique et c'est manu l'annuel
emmanuel annuel d'être inconnu ici il se
produit beaucoup au quartz il fait des
tournées dans toute la france et bien
sûr en bretagne on le connaît bien
manuel annuel chante vent force brest
[Musique]
sans de l'océan
voulant mar azul et la colère ou devant
habite légal
il est 7 heures du charme de brefs
d'horizons et faire l'hiver mais elle de
tempête on dépollue de shit en pâtes ou
de tête très brillant c'est cuit perdre
le nord à l'envers sous la pluie de
braises
j'ai nommé l'envers sous la pluie de
braises tribord amure bord du uss
réchauffe les membrures avant de
rembarquer ya des bouquets de brume aux
saveurs des sous leurs couleurs caramel
sous la bible de brax
la terre à la mer une voiture flux comme
une lame en moi une lan ou de doit
saluer la falaise en brisant le front me
vire en bande mou sous la pluie bhl de
brest
ma vie rendant debout sous la pluie de
braises
l'orage de toit tandis que je marche des
femmes de la nuit et des hommes de ross
en piquant des étoiles dans mon arbre de
planches à remonter le temps
[Musique]
la fin du jour à lui de la même c'est
toi tu es légumes ou ge dans ma mémoire
tu marches sur la dune dans la lumière
il fait beau comme hier sous la bible de
braise il fait beaucoup mieux
sous la pluie de braises on s'en va ce
parti
bonsoir d'amour il s'est mis à genoux à
dieu va te laisse courir sur le souvenir
sous le soleil qui pleure tu appuies
bleu de bresse
lieu de cargo noir liste couler le sang
de l'océan coulant marin sauver la terre
du vent à toutes les galères il est 7
heures ce soir sous la pluie de brest à
dieu vat laisse courir vous le souvenir
à bout
[Musique]
bagnols annuel si je dis chanteur breton
sujet ça c'est bien ou sata gas ça c'est
bien et ça m'agace un peu ce que je dis
plutôt chanteur de bretagne oui parce
que je crois que non parce qu'ils aient
eu la vague un peu folklo des années 70
75 d'abord ça a été très fort et puis
après on a dit que c'était folklo mais
pas forcément parce qu'ils en ont pas
forcément il y avait des gens comme nous
il y avait des gens qui faisaient delà
de la musique que le traditionnel habit
traditionnel c'est aussi un chose
d'important à garder je veux dire et
puis je crois qu on raconte que jamais
un peu comme ça ses racines profondes
c'est à dire moi je joue à nancy
des fois quand deux buts ça ça vaut
brest bon moi c'est brest et légendes
brest ya deux choses qui est intéressant
est vrai c'est que si on s'arrête à la
façade effectivement on s'arrête là donc
on s'arrête mais si on continue tuant
tous les pores derrière on trouve l'âme
des gens et effectivement il ya une
amitié conquis à ici enfin une amitié
une relation humaine qu'on peut trouver
avec les gens ici parce que ces objets
de lutter contre contre l'autre cette
grisaille et tout donc ils luttent avec
de l'amitié avec de l'amour des choses
comme ça plus qu'avec qu'avec d'autres
choses donc c'est celle c'est là qu'est
l'intérêt je crois
quelqu'un a parlé de la pluie bleus de
brest lui bleus c'est une chaleur un
trophée laquelle les bleus ouais quand
elle tombe je pars il ya souvent un mais
ça se retrouve dans beaucoup de régions
de bretagne comme ça il ya une pluie et
puis y'a quand même des trous dans le
ciel enfin des trous des trous bleus qui
font que la la pluie comme ça qui tombe
il est un peu salvatrice révèle même
merci manuel annuel et justement on va
les voir le capitaine de l'abeille
flandre ce remorqueur de haute mer
qu'elle serait déjà prendre jean et son
capitaine s'appelle jean bulot
bonjour commandant merci de m'accueillir
à bord de réveil flandre je me surprends
plein veille là en plein permanence
est-ce que vous avez une idée du nombre
de marins aient pu se courir avec le
label island en 15 ans l'a fait un petit
bilan et on assister environ 8 milles
marins milles marins
et sauvé d'une mort certaine une sans
sauver d'une mort certaine les marins
qui vraiment était en détresse qui était
prêt naufrage de secours et les petits
bateaux comme les gros toutou du
pétrolier jusqu'au même on a récupéré
des véliplanchistes nom passant par les
petits bateaux kg combattre jeu des
voiliers
[Musique]
même transocéanique catamaran autre
remorqueur est capable de tirer
n'importe quel pétrolier 10 ou même si
les pins absolument à la suite de
l'amoco on a fait des essais avec les
superpétroliers 550 mille tonnes
on a chargé au maximum dont ça faisait
un déplacement total 2 poids 2 642
milton et on a réussi à les remonter à
force 8 75% de puissance à 4,9 et vous
avez évité un eschoise s'attend on à
éviter pas mal de marée noire puisque en
a sauvé avant la ramener à peu près
presque 200 bateaux ici des qui comptait
des petits marée noire mais enfin le
celui qui restera si vous laissez le
remorquage du tanio le pen héritage du
tanio qui s'est cassé en deux deux ans
après l'amour au canigou quand il mange
beaucoup jo et l'avant a coulé une
tempête quand même de 10 12
et voilà ce moment là je suis content et
l'abeille languedoc il susurre suis plus
solide du président à cherbourg et
l'arrière continue à flotter l'équipage
avait évacué par hélicoptère de l'encore
12000 tonnes de pétrole brut à
l'intérieur et le bateau était rendu à
un demi-mille des cailloux du côté de au
large de paimpol est aidée cet ebook et
on a réussi à faire monter à bord deux
hommes la veille le second cabinet deux
heures de rire et me paraît quinze via
quelques défauts quand même 7 mm ils ont
grimpé par une échappée de
de mazout et on a réussi à passer
d'armor qui a récupéré le bateau à un
degré de l'équipe
ça doit être vraiment impressionnants de
se présenter avec votre bateau et sa
part un petit bateau mais quand même il
est petit quand il se présente devant
l'étrave d'un immense pétrolier n'est
pas un petit peu je ne dis pas un marin
mais un petit peu peur quand on
travaille avec des creux de 10 mètres ou
plus
elles vont se présente le cul devant le
cul dans le mans a touché le vent le
l'étrave du bâteau des fois on frôle
d'autres maîtres et les gars des les
hommes derrière c'est eux qui sont plus
exposés puisque tous les paquets de mer
embarque pas soit la plage derrière et
des fois moins que la facel je les vois
plus et ils sont pas mariés peuvent pas
être marié non parce que ce serait plus
dangereux qu'autre chose et il suffira à
ce moment là qu'ils se brel le leboutou
dans leur saisine quelque part et puis
le un fil d'acier fouette à ce moment là
elles sont efficaces et qui sont gros
comme ça qui pèse 20 km à l'est des
hommes serait coupée en deux ou parce
que leur support
[Musique]
le
manuel annuel est venu souvent chanté
ici là produit des spectacles
et puis il a fait partie qu'il fait
toujours partie de ces grandes voix de
bretagne qui sont venus chanter ici
avant d'aller au théâtre de la ville
et ici c'est quoi c'est le quartz est
une autre vitrine de brest une vitrine
culturelle est beaucoup plus qu'une
vitrine ici se tiennent des congrès bien
sûr les vedettes en tournée il passe
mais il ya de la création et vous allez
voir pas n'importe laquelle
on va voir son directeur jacques blanc
jacques blanc bonjour alors vous nous
accueillez la boucle directeur du quartz
qu'on appelle encore une palette des
cultures c'est un bien grand mot au
palais que de bresse vous accueillez
dans la plus petite de vossa c'est ça
oui ça c'est le ce qu'on appelle le
petit théâtre donc il ya deux jusqu'à il
ya deux têtes il ya un théâtre de 1500
places et puis un théâtre donc de 300
places qui celui là et ici donc il ya un
jeune metteur en scène qui est en ce
moment
michel bernos michel vergoz qui crée en
ce moment une pièce en france qui
s'appelle master classes dans les quatre
personnages sont joseph staline son
ministre dano chostakovitch le musicien
et prokofiev un autre musicien et alors
et alors ça se passe mal pour les
musiciens parce que c'est aline vaudan
que la musique soit comme ça et pas
autrement
oui c'est ça ils pensent qu'ils font une
musique trop intellectuel et voudrait
que ses musiciens la face une musique
plus populaire plus près de lamu russe
alors justement on va pas faire de
raccourcis audacieux mais quels sont les
rapports de la culture et de la
politique brest même plutôt sain plutôt
bien c'est à dire que les les gens qui
s'occupent de la politique je crois en
respect démocratique de la liberté des
artistes et de la liberté des gens qui
s'occupent de culture donc ça fonctionne
bien c'est à dire que les instances sont
autonomes et en même temps sont
complémentaires et puis ils ont fait
quelque chose d'intéressant la ville a
fait quelque chose d'intéressant pour
développer une idée que vous aviez déjà
oui c'est à dire c'est cette idée des
dents lieu d'une ville qui serait un peu
la cité des artistes résidents c'est à
dire qu'ils nous ont prêté un manoir qui
est magnifique manoir de keroual d'une
au manoir du xviiie siècle
quelle chance oui c'est ce match superbe
wayne wiz habite où l'équipe qui répète
donc master-class habitons cependant sur
deux vilains médicis c'est oui on
appelle ça un peu nous la villa médicis
bretonne et toute l'année donc à des
artistes qui sont là en résidence qui
travaillent avec nous toute l'année
c'est à dire des acteurs des danseurs et
des musiciens et ça je crois que c'est
une des singularités qu'on m'a mis dans
cette région et cette ville en fait de
la politique culturelle de la ville
bon j insiste vous fait il sait des
créations à caractère national comme on
dit
il ya vu qu est-ce qui est par exemple
vient de faire la dernière création du
cirque archaos don qui est venu ici qu a
séjourné ici ils ont sorti leur
spectacle ici la prochaine donc master
class va se jouer un mois à paris faust
par un jeune metteur en scène qui
s'appelle dominique pitoiset sera jouée
à moi à l'athénée et c'est donc les
spectacles ont créé ici voyage c'est à
dire qu'ils ne sont pas uniquement à
vocation locale c'est là dans ce sens
l'importance qu'il ya une grande
importance de la danse effectivement les
je crois que les plus grands
chorégraphes français sont nuls à même
le ballet de l'opéra de paris il y aura
fait une création ici une fois et pour
nous c'est très très important c'est un
pays aussi où nous imprimons bouge et où
on chante dont il ya une tradition
peut-être plus forts de ce côté là du
côté du théâtre
merci jacques blanc
[Musique]
derrière ces palissades de chantier bon
un chantier comme tous les autres
chantiers n'ont pas vraiment bien ici va
s'élever la nouvelle faculté des lettres
en plein centre-ville et elle
accueillera une partie des vingt mille
étudiants de brest famille l'étudiant si
on compte l'université et les grandes
écoles alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'en même temps que va s'ouvrir
cette faculté est bien s'achèvera la
technopole de sainte anne du portzic une
technopole où on a voulu regrouper les
établissements d'enseignement et de
recherche
et puis les entreprises qui travaillent
dans ce qu'on appelle les technologies
nouvelles
alors former les cerveaux c'est bien les
retenir à brest c'est une autre
politique de longue haleine et c'est
pourquoi nous allons voir le président
de l'université de bretagne occidentale
ce présent merci nous recevoir
jean claude doré cboe qui vous remercie
de votre visite votre université
travaille sur quelques grands axes
j'aimerais bien savoir ok bon disons
d'entrée de jeu que c'est une université
pluridisciplinaire c'est à dire que nous
avons finalement la plupart des
activités ici sur le site de pratiquer
toutes les universités
c'est évident il y a des choix à faire
et il ya de grandes orientations la
maison nous soutenons à bras
je pense notamment spécifique à brest
oui le monde sciences de la mer
un certain nombre de laboratoires
reconnus par le cnrc et d'autres
structures également aux sciences de
l'agriculture et du monde rural
bon vous avez une forte composante
également civilisations cultures par le
biais du centre de recherche bretonne et
celtique qui a une très bonne notoriété
ici et même à une échelle nationale
la grande question jean claude bourret
c'est comment fixer les cerveaux une
fois qu'ils sont formés comment les
fixes et ici dans cette région je crois
qu'on a des atouts à faire valoir dans
ce pays globalement à la condition que
les gens comprennent que bon bref ce
n'est pas un ghetto de la même façon le
sud finistère est étroitement solidaires
du nord-finistère je crois qu'on doit
jouer la carte de la bretagne
occidentale sur un plan universitaire
mais aussi sur un plan économique
globalement pas en petite chapelle
séparé est divisée est ce que cette
région d'europe ne serait pas la région
brestoise ne serait pas le bout l'europe
mais qui serait fermée sur elle même
alors ça c'est une idée intéressante
telle que voulue les mettez je trouve
moi personnellement que cette situation
géographique est une situation
éminemment original
alors bien entendu nous sommes
relativement isolé c'est certainement un
point de faiblesse mais paradoxalement
aussi si on y regarde d'un tout petit
peu près ça peut être un point de
vitalité de force
vous savez on a lavé au nord la mer à
l'ouest vers l'est devant dans les
allemands ça nous entraîne à développer
des ramifications plus que d'autres à
ressentir le besoin de ses ramifications
plus que d'autres et d'important pour
nous développer ce qu'on appelle un
réseau bleu on met ça sur pied à l'heure
actuelle ça marche bien et on fonctionne
avec voir qu'une série réseau bleu c'est
la mer c'est les sciences de la mer mais
pas uniquement sur le site de brestois
ce qui nous intéressait aussi le
développement avec concarneau
laboratoire du collège de france avec
roscoff
il y à là centre océanologique qui
dépend de l'université paris 6 avec
l'université de rennes 1 à 1 avec
l'université de nantes avec eux toutes
les structures finalement sur un blanc
breton sens large du terme qui nous
intéressent très directement dont on se
développe de cette manière
pas dans le repliement locales ou ultra
régionales
on va me fit en ramifie également vers
l'extérieur c'est-à-dire vers l'europe
est également en direction de pays non
européens
merci monsieur le président et
maintenant nous allons faire une visite
à une pme de brest qui est conduite par
une par une femme et c'est assez rare
dans cette région c'est assez rare en
france aussi une pédégère
récemment le magazine économique
entreprendre a désigné une brestoise
d'adoption comme une des meilleures
femmes dirigeantes d'entreprises alors
nous avons évidemment voulu aller
d'avoir il s'agit d'elisabeth qu'abbas
bien connu des amateurs défi puisque ici
on fabrique des haut parleurs des
enceintes acoustiques et c'est alors
j'ai beaucoup de questions à poser un
même qu'à basse sur brest pourquoi elle
est à brest et on quand il commence une
entreprise se développe et puis
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'elle cogite
autour de l'emploi à brest mais je
voudrais d'abord vous montrer quelque
chose que j'ai jamais vu que j'avais
jamais vu mais maintenant je les ai vus
messieurs vous la montrer c'est une
chambre sourde
c'est là qu'on étudie ces l'agro vérifie
qu'on contrôle conteste de les fameux
haut parleur est enceinte acoustique à
regarder c'est assez étonnant non je ne
sais pas si vous le son vous arrive
missile est complètement uniforme ya pas
d co et naturellement du découpage a été
fait pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'écho que
les vérifications soit bien conforme à
ce qui a été prévu
alors je vais maintenant accueillir même
qu à base d'os dans sa chambre sourbes
c'est étonnant cet endroit vos enceintes
là elles sont remarquables ils servent à
quoi
alors hop tout document déjà elle et
c'est la dernière création est la
dernière création c'est un nouveau une
nouvelle conception technologique de 2
haut-parleurs coaxial elle sert elle
peut servir à la fois pour des amateurs
- je vous sors plus de temps que
nécessaire
ça vaut combien ça
p cent mille francs l'unité l'unité
bref c'est le bout du monde et beaucoup
de gens qui disent ça c'est vous du
monde s'appelle bout du monde ya 30 ans
maintenant c'est plus bout du monde une
heure d'avion de paris 5 avions par jour
le tgv du bonne route
à mon avis on met une heure à une heure
pour aller à paris a beaucoup de gens
qui font ça tous les jours pour aller
devant lui à paris pour travailler
oui mais ici c'est un chant de matière
grise on forme des cerveaux les
entreprises s'installent mais comment
finalement retenir tout ça parce que il
ya eu des fuites qui a des inspirations
ya rennes qui était compétitive aussi
avec brest et puis elle reste de
l'europe
alors comment faire pour l'aimer pour
maintenir ce potentiel ici comme pour
tout dans la vie faut analyser ces
atouts nous en avons que les autres
n'ont pas d'abord nous avons la mer est
il sain il faut le dire beaucoup aux
bretons parce qu'ils ont tellement vite
fait savoir qu'ils ne se rendent pas
compte à quel point c'est extraordinaire
d'être au bord de la mer va tous les
matins quand je me lève je regarde par
la fenêtre je regarde la mer je passerai
pas une bonne journée s'il n'avait pas
jeté un coup d'oeil sur la mer avant de
me lever je crois que je crois que pour
beaucoup de gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur c'est quelque chose ils sont
très profondément peut-être plus que les
peut-être plus que les brestois
c'est une ville chaude chaleureux et
aussi pratique c'est à dire que vous ne
vous ne perdez pas quand je quand je
calcule ce que ce que les gens à paris
perte de temps en recherche de parking à
faire leurs courses aller à leur trajet
et bien si je sauve deux ou trois heures
par jour pour pour faire d'autres choses
plus intéressantes
j'estime que j'ai que j'ai une chance
énorme mais je vous remercie elisabeth
cammas
et maintenant partons en rade de brest
oui souvenez-vous aux sables d'olonne
nous avons assisté au départ de vendée
globe et les rescapés continuent leur
tour du monde sur leur monocoque
pendant ce temps là d'autres navigateurs
se prépare un tour du monde façon jules
verne en 80 jours à concarneau
nous avions rencontré olivier de
kersauson il n'avait pas voulu nous
montrer son trimaran en construction et
le voilà qui navigue en rade de brest
les navigateurs adore la rade de brest
valérie heurtel a vu naviguer le charal
depuis quelques jours la curiosité du
port du moulin blanc c'est charal un
catamaran de 27 mètres de long qui se
prépare tout doucement à faire le tour
du monde en 80 jours
depuis une semaine charal est en période
d'essai sous la main experte d'un quart
seront tendus concentré mais confiant
dans son patelin bateau qu'on a fait
dans l'esprit de tout le monde donc il
n'y a pas le même rapport de puissance
caution à 60 pieds comme et remo mais
c'est quand même un bateau un bateau de
glisse passé un grand bateau c'est un
bateau pour aller dans le sud
pourquoi on dit que cfoot partir faire
le tour du monde sur un multicoque plus
que ce round 4 est tout le monde dit que
les choses sont folles à andy de kayes
et foulon 19 ans en guadeloupe je vois
c'est plus spécial restait que un
multicoque chi
si on se retrouve couché sur le côté
quoi où comment s'allumant sur les bras
parce qu'à elle elle c'est pas le même
pilotage pour faire attention je sais
certaines conditions ça peut être
[Musique]
c'est par où passer le tour du monde n'y
a pas 36 manières on descend
l'atlantique on coupe l'équateur on
passe ou l'afrique du sud les îles
kerguelen entre entre tous qui a tout ce
qui reste de terres l'hémisphère sud et
le continent antarctique en enrayant
mission d'aller à ses traits du
continent entre actifs placard ou qui
est plus court en même temps en évitant
le
on vous voit cependant à la casse qui a
eu justement sur les bateaux de ce parti
les ennuis comme les skippers commencé à
m'angoisser pour les en vidéo je me sens
très bien à dépasser janvier à la partie
du cas aujourd'hui en stand by
et pourquoi vous avez choisi partir de
brest alors parce que j'aime bien j'aime
bien voir plus bref c'est un vrai point
de départ s'est situé à 48,30 nord donc
ça fait c'est l'entrée de la manche
c'est une rade abri formidable c'est un
poste d'attentes formidable
et puis j'aime bien moins agitée que je
trouve ça plus plus élégant de partir de
chez nous pour rentrer chez nous
[Musique]
si l'archevêque de lyon et le primat des
gaules
le préfet maritime de brest personnalise
la souveraineté française sur ces
grandes eaux territoriales qui surveille
en permanence
il a sous ses ordres tous les services
dits du rail d'ouessant brest par lui
contrôle et protège les abords de
l'europe de l'europe la circulation
rapide et pointilleuse des milliers de
navires de tous tonnages et de tout
pavillon qui emprunte une des oceanes
aux routes les plus fréquentées d'europe
voilà ce qu'écrivait henri queffélec
alors le préfet maritime le l'amiral
merveilleux du vignaux et il le primat
de brest encore aujourd'hui nous allons
le lui demander
[Musique]
monsieur le préfet vient sinon je viens
de vous présenter comme le primat de
brest c'est pas moi qui écris ça c'est
henri queffélec qui disait que vous
étiez ici le représentant de la
souveraineté nationale en surveillant
d'un arabe le rail d'ouessant etc
oui oui il me fait pas siffler à
rectifier il parlait de tous les procès
maritime pas seulement de vous donner la
fonction je me garderai bien de ma place
met à la place de la fonction supprima
sur la mer bat l'egypte à la privation
la terre bien sûr c'est la première
chose oui ça représente ici là la
puissance de la nation et c'est une
puissance qui s'exprime de façon navale
ici c'est la puissance pas vraiment sur
le littoral
la puissance outre-mer c'est ma chanson
loin oui la marine c'est un instrument
du matin quel est l'état de l'osmose
qu'on a pu décrire entre les brestois et
leur marine nationale
je crois que je crois qu'elle est qu'on
m'a dit qu'elle a eu plein d'accrocs
qu'elle a eu des dents je crois qu'elle
est complète elle a des accrocs mais
comme tout mariage à des accrocs et ils
sont brest est née avec la marine j'ai à
dire est qu'elle est née de la marine
parce que avant qu'ils aient la ville de
brest
il y avait ici d'abord une implantation
militaire palais l'histoire du château
en montrait trop loin mais il y avait
une implantation de la marine qui a
utilisé ce extraordinaire peur naturelle
va qui est à nos pieds
et puis autour de ça s'est constitué ce
qu'il fallait pour faire une marine
c'est l'histoire de caulker du xviiie ne
soit un bref en pas refaire l'histoire
et de sa est né un mariage alors j'ai
pas c'est un mariage d'amour ou de
raison mais en tout cas c'est un mariage
et comme tous les mariages y aller il ya
des explications de temps en temps pour
les vo est totale au total
tout ça ça marche ensemble et tout le
monde est convaincu que ça ne peut pas
marcher autrement oui mais bon le
brestois s'inquiète aujourd'hui il se
demande si la marine ne va pas leur
glisser dans les doigts savez on
s'inquiète toujours les choses changent
et la seule manière de pas inquiet du
tout ça serait jamais rien changé ce qui
vient contraire la nature humaine
alors il faut bien changer un peu la
vérité enfin les lignes du les lignes de
force du long terme je crois qu'il faut
voir c'est que la marine nationale
elle ne peut pas ne pas être présente
sur la façade de la france dont eva
l'atlantique
à ce jour une chose le poids énorme de
vente de ce menu le prénom c'est ici ce
port c'est le grand port du ponant à
d'autres c'est la sentinelle de l'europe
encore quand le soir la sentinelle de la
france d'abord c'est le point de départ
puisque la sentinelle peut-être enfin
oui c'est la sentinelle pour tout ce qui
passe devant ça c'est une autre aspect
des choses qui tournaient vers la
sécurité' nos côtes la vie quand la
pollution dans un domaine de défense
je crois que c'est d'abord le point de
départ est la bretagne c'est celle entre
mythe et l'europe même si la france a
peur et la marine nationale est
aujourd'hui à brest
je suis convaincu que dans cent ans elle
y sera toujours il ya une construction
navale qui se ralentit on fait le
charles de gaulle mais en france non pas
deux alors attendez d'abord ne me faites
pas dire malfrats pas deux sur tout ce
que j'ai lu dans les journaux pour
l'instant on en fait un et un bon c'est
un effort qui va durer encore pendant
longtemps c'est ici dans cette bretagne
à cette fonte de bretagne que se
construit au moins que s'élabore
l'essentiel de ce que sera demain
le type d'action navale française tête
un jour européenne c'est le grand porte
avions notre mesurer seine-maritime vous
n'êtes pas responsable des réductions
d'emplois mais existent et inquiète
brestois évidemment il ya des réductions
à toi mais qui sont qui sont certes à
l'ordre du jour à l'heure actuelle qui
sont pas considérables pour l'instant il
n'y en a pas dans le domaine militaire
maintenant il ya eu quelques mouvements
de personnel entre port mais au total le
total des postes militaires qui sont
dans la région brestoise est resté le
même
au pied quand même temps il fera partie
soit ou non mais s'il ya dix-huit mille
militaires et environ neuf mille civils
qui travaillent pour la défense à
travers les marines et là quelques
fluctuations en tournée ce chiffre
certes en diminution et depuis quelques
années d'ailleurs mais pas en diminution
drastique
cette année plus que les précédentes
c'est un effort de contraction générale
qui correspond ce que vous disiez
d'ailleurs qui se fait mais qui doit
préserver l'essentiel n'est pas question
de faire imploser le système
monsieur bérégovoy est venu ici pour le
départ de la jeanne d'arc
bon on a interprété son discours comme
mons eu ce qu'on sait déjà des réalités
économiques de la france c'est-à-dire
dans une rigueur qu'il faut accepter
budgétaire et il ya aussi un désarmement
au relatif mondial et il faut faire avec
et pendant ce temps là il y avait 12
cents manifestants qui
de l'arsenal qui s'inquiétaient pour
leur emploi voilà c'est je résume en
gros vous nom du départ de la jeanne
d'arc
c'est un résumé qui est nettement plus
clavier du poids mini c'est là que les
conditions de l'exercice de la défense
d'aujourd'hui que vous décrivez là une
limitation des dépenses et bien sûr
limitons les dépenses à ce qu'il faut
pour avoir l'outil nécessaire
pas plus mais ayant l'outil nécessaire
je crois que c'est le discours que tout
le monde doit pouvoir tenir là
aujourd'hui il faut pas voir la
bouteille à moitié vide il faut voir la
bouteille à moitié pleine
aussi quand même on fabrique ici lui un
des principaux outils la défense de
demain il y à issy de l'autre côté de
cette rade
l'épiné dorsale de la défense alors là
sur le long terme stratégique nucléaire
de la france donc peut-être qu est ce
qui a ramené les brestois à la mer sont
peut-être pas les bateaux de guerre sont
les vieux gréements devresse 92 je crois
qu'on peut aimer les vieux gréements
parce que émotionnellement on aime ce
qui est sur l'eau on aime soit même
d'arriver et beaucoup de brestois comme
moi parce que ce sont des gens du
littoral sont des gens qui est à blâmer
mais ça n'empêche pas la modernité
il peut y avoir en même temps je le
disais un jour on a construit la
recouvrance là aussi sous un hangar pour
deux commerces à peu près 400 mètres
plus à l'ouest
yann charles de gaulle dans un bassin
ils sont parallèles il était parallèle
les lignes de teint était parallèle et
non à l'autre c'est très symbolique ce
elle même reste la même ville de brest
que ça se construisait c'étaient des
ouvriers qui les uns étaient des
ouvriers de la charpente en bois
excellent artisan du gîte la
construction en bois l'autre côté de
dons moins bon je n'ose pas dire
artisans mais le monal m ouvriers un peu
vain un fabricant de la fabrication à
faire et de la haute technologie
électronique et tout ça qui va tuer des
choses du nucléaire mais tout ça ça
forme un touche à tout dans une société
je remercie infiniment admirable je vous
en prie
hommage à deux vieux brestois disparu
georges michel thomas et pierre perron
brest en plein d'envié je n'ai rien
inventé et en composant ce livre georges
michel thomas a voulu utiliser
bien sûr les peintures les croquis de
pierre perron qui étaient ici un peintre
renommé pas trop de la marine a aussi
beaucoup peint la ville évidemment une
célébrité on l'appelle victor hugo de
brest et france 3 a gardées bien sûr le
souvenir de pierre péan au début j'ai
beaucoup de fans beaucoup plus précises
beaucoup plus vous dirai pas que le
trafic mais beaucoup plus classique
maintenant beaucoup moins je me dis ça
je peux faire aussi bien là aussi bien
non pas aussi bien mais je peux faire la
peinture abstraite également ma pensée
tout à fait d'ici cet autre chose d'être
calé la batture abstrait prophète n'a
pas le touche-à-tout fait avec plaisir
et vais jouer et on peut aussi peint en
chansons mac orlan ça va être très bien
faire ça claude leroux une brestoise
accompli chante fanny fanny de laninon
le vita club
son cahier du nid dans l'accueil ends et
du soir
après je ne sais quel sur chavez dans le
coeur une souffrance dans le quartier
mccaw néron sonic ordre courant ce
profit de la nuit la plus belle que la n
11 panis caire prose ma frite un ponton
à propos de fantaisie c'était tellement
à konami l'écran tétreault discours
rempli de me battre devant le dépôt
quand je ne me sens jamais plaisir
j'aime mieux mais tournée que devait
s'ouvrir aux fans où je m'étais yeux
marrons cependant j'espère d'élégance
fait pas lancer le var moi je n'étais
pas de la maison se met jamais là tout
en main tendue ne voir le dimanche
mon cheveu sur du gué train reste où je
suis retourné tout métro timonier au
procès je sais je suis au service des
parts
tg couple apporte à la mer en son
tourment de molène à wissant quand
souffle le froid
tonnerre de brest est tombé pas du bon
côté
tout s'est écroulé dans ce qui reste la
[Musique]
roseraie plus à sa cour
c'est pas de ma reconnaissance je
m'entends 110 g pour rien survivance mac
en jeu pour à un couteau je sais que ma
dernière chance sera fait rage dans le
[Musique]
bien sûr ne peut pas quitter brest sans
évoquer le fabuleux rendez-vous des
vieux gréements brest 92
mais qu'est-ce que ça laissait à brest
une fois que les lampions comme on dit
ont été éteints et bien valérie heurtel
a voulu s'en rendre compte
[Musique]
juillet 92,1 sur les rives de la penfeld
la fête bat son plein mélange de
couleurs ou de sont provoqués par la
poule ils ne sont plus d'un million
venus de toute l'europe au rendez-vous
les vieux gréements programmée de longue
date
[Musique]
à
sur l'eau sans complexe les petits
bateaux se mesurent à leur grand frère
embarcations fragile et sans prétention
à côté des grands voiliers d'apparat
[Musique]
cet été là beaucoup de brestois ont
différé leurs vacances pour voir leur
ville en fête pour la première fois
depuis bien longtemps
ils vont pouvoir descendre sur les rives
de la penfeld retrouver deux petits
ponts guesdon qui reliait autrefois
recouvrance au bas de la rue thiam
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé formidable de voir le
château fut de l'intérieur de j'avais
jamais vu sous cet angle là de lapin
salle d'hawaï de l'intérieur de
l'arsenal je trouve que c'est dommage
qu'on puisse pas y aller plus souvent
c'était chouette de voir que les gens de
l'est pour notre ville que j'ai été à
coup de pierres de star oui bien sûr la
ville de brest avait changé n'ont pas de
nom pas d'aspect et presque les maisons
se sont mises à sourire malgré la pluie
qui a eu quelques fois les brestois
avaient argué vous n'êtes pas senti
envahi un peu avec tous ces visiteurs
non ça vous a fait plaisir au contraire
parce qu'elle est et on voit pas souvent
de brest n'est quand même pas une ville
très touristique c'est vrai et bien de
les avoir attiré autant de monde comme
ça ça me fait peur qu'une bonne
propagande pour les années à venir
aujourd'hui les militaires nouveau
thriller droit et le petit point guidon
ne souffre plus que sur des bateaux gris
[Musique]
le port a retrouvé son calme mais sur
les quais les couleurs des maisons garde
le souvenir d'une fête magique où brest
à renouer avec cette tradition fiers les
brestois
oui ils sont fiers d'avoir su pour
quelques jours transformer leur petit
bout du monde en un très grand voyage
[Musique]
samedi prochain nous allons rêver et
même nous ne ferons que cela nous serons
dans la forêt de brocéliande où
s'entrecroisent sur ces chemins toutes
les légendes de bretagne et ainsi nous
nous ouvrirons l'imaginaire propice à la
semaine de noël
c'est à travers les mots et l'esprit des
compteurs que nous flâneront et surtout
avec le maître du genre pierre-jakez
hélias et j'espère j'espère que les
elfes et des lutins montreront le bout
de leur nez à samedi
[Musique]